fifinalement! Merci beaucoup,
memerci, Suzanne.
U Une nouvelle étude publiée
dadans la revue Science Advances
momontre que le vaccin contre
lala COVID-19 pouvait perturber
leles menstruations des personns
nonormalement menstruées,
etet de nouvelles observations
pepermettent de constater que
leles femmes ménopausées ou ence
dedes hommes transgenres sont
auaussi touchés, notamment
papar des saignements
plplus abondants. On en discute
avavec Diane Francoeur, médecin
obobstétricienne-gynécologue
auau CHU Sainte Justine.
MeMerci d'être là pour nous parr
dede ses recherches. C'est un
tetexte qui attire beaucoup
l'l'attention sur le site Web de
RaRadio-Canada. Avez-vous remaré
dedes impacts liés au vaccin sur
lele cycle menstruel?
- - On a remarqué beaucoup de
chchangement menstruel relié à
totout ce qui est autour de la
COCOVID. Évidemment ce qui touce
lala régularité du cycle menstrl
c'c'est beaucoup le stress, et
susurtout dansns la première vae
avavec le confinement, on a vu r
exexemple chez les jeunes
adadolescentes une prise de pois
énénorme. Et on a vu beaucoup de
jejeunes filles et de jeunes
fefemmes qui consultaient pour s
irirrégularités. Lorsque les
vavaccins sont arrivés certains
onont dit que ça pouvait avoir n
imimpact mais c'est toujours
didifficile de savoir sans les
dodonnés scientifiques systèmes
peperception ou l'inquiétude. E-
cece que c'était une façon
d'd'essayer de convaincre les
pepersonnes pouvant être enceine
dede ne pas se faire vacciner. n
esessaie d'avoir le plus de
dodonnées possibles. Il y a 40 0
pepersonnes qui ont répondu et
c'c'est effectivement la premièe
ététude qui regarde aussi l'impt
auau niveau par exemple des
pepersonnes trance et des femmes
méménopausées. Maintenant avante
didire que c'est les vaccins, on
n'n'en est pas là, il faudrait
cocomparer avec un groupe de
pepersonnes pouvant être enceine
ququi n'ont pas eu de changement
dadans leur menstruation. J'espe
ququ'on va voir ses études là pr
popouvoir vérifier et rassurer s
pepersonnes pouvant être encein.
Pour l'instant on n'en est pas
llà.
- - Pas facile de bien cernait
s's'il y a un impact direct du
vavaccin parce que vous lavez
mementionner qu'il y a beaucoupe
fafacteurs qui peuvent perturber
lele cycle menstruel.
- - Tout à fait c'est importante
rassssurer les gens : la COVID t
unune vraie maladie. Les persons
ququi vontnt se retrouver avec e
COCOVID longue et des
cocomplications à long terme dea
COCOVID, c'est une réalité. Ce
n'n'est pas des histoires et c't
popour ça que je pense queue les
gegens doivent continuer. Si ona
6565 % de gens qui ont eu la COD
rérécemment qui ne sont pas
mamalades et qui ne sont pas
l'l'hôpital, c'est parce que les
vavaccins fonctionnent aussi. Il
fafaut prendre et par la part ds
chchoses et ne pas démoraliser a
vavaccination. Cela dit on a
vavacciné beaucoup de gens avec
plplusieurs doses, on prévoit ce
ququi arrive à l'automne et on e
prprépara tout comme d'habitude.
AuAujourd'hui au moment où on se
paparle même si on a cette étude
llà qu'il y a des changement
memenstruel, ce n'est pas
dadangereux et ce n'est pas une
raraison pour ne pas se faire
vavacciner. Le pire qu'il peut
ararriver lorsqu'on a des
irirrégularités menstruelles,
c'c'est une grossesse qui n'état
papas prévue. On a suffisamment
paparlé d'accès à l'avortement
dadans les dernières semaines pr
mimieux savoir qu'on ne voudrait
papas que ça arrive la personne.
DoDonc c'est important pour savr
sisi les gens ont des menstruatn
irirrégulière de ne pas
s's'inquiéter.
- - Donc vous vous faites
rarassurante par rapport au vacn
enen disant : il faut continuere
sese faire vacciner contre la
COCOVID 19 et ne pas craindre qe
ceces impacts la plus avoir des
coconséquences importantes sur a
sasanté, finalement, une
peperturbation du cycle menstru?
- - Tout à fait et je pense qu'n
veveut aussi avoir les données.
VoVous savait que nous à Sainte-
JuJustine on a cohorte de femmes
enenceintes pour la COVID qu'ona
ararrêté parce qu'on n'a pas de
fifinancement pour la continuer.
PoPourtant la COVID n'est pas
teterminée et on peut avoir les
dodonnées québécoises, on veut
sasavoir attaquer ce qui arrive
auaux gens d'ici au Québec. Oui,
ilil faut se questionner et resr
dadans le radar est toujours reé
ououvert parce que vous savez qe
mmême si on n'a pas de lien
didirect maintenant aujourd'hui,
ilil y a quand même d'autres
ététudes qui ont été prouvées sr
lele sujet récemment. Il faut
ququand même toujours rester
sususpicieux. Alors quand les
fefemmes rapportent quelque cho,
onon peut les rassurer, mais par
cocontre il faut continuer à les
susurveiller. Est-ce que quand n
auaura plus de femmes on sera en
memesure d'évaluer d'autres
imimpacts? On a vu que la COVID
esest un virus particulier et oa
eueu des problèmes gynécologiqus
cocomme des ulcères, quelque che
ququi est associé au virus aveca
COCOVID, avec le vaccin même si
c'c'est pas un virus vivant, ona
vuvu que des ulcères reviennentà
chchaque destination. C'est
ququelque chose qui a été rappoé
ququ'on arrive pas à expliquer
scscientifiquement, mais les fas
sosont là. Il faut continuer à
susurveiller et on est toujoursn
momode de surveillance. On
susurveille tout ce qui se passe
susur le terrain, mais au moment
ouoù on se parle aujourd'hui je
pepense qu'on peut se rassurer.
- - Comme quoi la recherche très
imimportante les données
scscientifiques extrêmement
prprécieus